wow  really  where have you been lizzie  i know that this is a thing yes but he  does that a lot yes okay  let him try yeah  he just does it so that i can be seen as  a babysitter yes  i'm just making wild noises putting my  hands over his yeah i put my hand over  his mouth and all sorts are there new  characters in this movie  no i didn't know that yeah it's  interesting because he you know it would  we were paired up a lot during the  avengers so i was literally oh my gosh  right of course you were diving on  grenades left right center it's kind of  fun it brightens up the day it makes me  look like a saying or at least better  than he is and i'm not sure i am it  would be on my own but with him  doing it intentionally no i don't know  no i don't i think possibly he's like  right come a match let's see how quick  he got something and i'm joking  i don't think so anyway